The king will die and if Ramirez
succeeds him war will follow
I wish to propose a marriage my daughter an
heir prepare egg on to rule a royal wedding
I hope to Herald in a second age of dragons
oh we're near a succession will
be challenged knives will come out
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my House of the Dragon episode 5 trailer video
we have a wedding weddings and Game of Thrones
wedding and House of the Dragon doesn't seem
like they work out too well because it's a giant
fight that breaks out you think of the Red Wedding
you think of the purple wedding Joffrey and Robb
Stark would be proud there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs here so I'll explain what's going
on if you're brand new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to subscribe
to get everything we're also doing a giveaway for
HBO Max subscriptions all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just post all your theories
about what happens in the trailer in the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of this too it
seems like corlys velaryon's ships are sailing to
the red keep for this wedding banquet that they're
having now she's wearing the wedding dress and all
these scenes in the red keep with his giant fees
so it's hard to tell if they've already had the
ceremony or if the ceremony itself is happening
somewhere separately but like right after it
seems like viserys actually comes to driftmark
to make the marriage proposal to corlys velaryon
to mend fences so to speak like he's coming to him
you remember that he just fired Otto Hightower as
hand of the king in last week's episode it seems
like it's been a relative really short time Jump
like not a lot of time goes by since the end of
episode four and it seems like lyonel strong is
the new hand the one that's standing next to him
here with the longer hair you remember he's the
person in episode 3 that was literally advising
him to have a marriage between rhaenyra and corlys
velaryon's son so that would explain why he's here
for this event you also notice ranera is walking
in behind him too next big scene in most of the
scenes in the trailer are at the actual Wedding
Banquet with everybody just celebrating the actual
match the dwarf here might actually be a version
of mushroom from the books so in the Fire and
Blood book The Story of the Targaryen family is
told across many different eras the dance of the
dragons are just part of that but the cool Easter
egg here is that a lot of the actual story comes
from second and third hand accounts one of them is
from mushroom who's telling them the story of all
these targaryens because of his disability the way
he looked he just wound up hearing a lot of other
Secrets people's tongues were way looser around
him because they didn't take him seriously kind
of what was happening in episode 3 with Lyonel
Strong's other son the disabled one larys the
clubfoot remember he sat down with all the women
to hear all the gossip if you believe the rumors
I feel that gods did not make me for hunting might
I sit with you my ladies give me all the tea you
have as they started spilling all their gossip and
it's just easier for him to pick up those things
with people not thinking about him as a big threat
because of his disability so it sounds like his
father and he himself used that to his Advantage
because the giant fight that breaks out here in
the middle of this seems like it has something to
do with what renera did during episode four like
all the drama in the spice from episode four so
I think it's pretty easy to assume that through
a number of different means secrets about what
actually happened start to get out and that's
what causes this giant brawl now because we make
all the Game of Thrones wedding jokes like the Red
Wedding with Robb Stark the purple wedding witch
offering I don't know that it gets quite to that
point but it looks like Criston Cole is gonna lay
waste to at least somebody during this trailer and
this actually looks like Joffrey lawnmuth who's
actually the rumored lover of laenor velaryon the
person that rhaenyra is supposed to marry one of
the big things about laenor velyaron obviously he
rides sea smoke that white dragon that we saw
in episode 3 which is really cool but in the
books it's rumored that he's actually gay and his
lover is Joffrey lawnmuth so there's just an added
layer of drama to everything that's going on with
all the characters like you have all the drama of
episode four but on top of that now rhaenyra is
kind of pushed into this marriage forced to marry
laenor velaryon even though he seems like a pretty
decent guy obviously if he's gay it's going to be
a really weird match for the two of them and it
kind of sounds like he doesn't want to get married
that much to her either or to anyone else for that
matter but his father corlys is so ambitious he's
been planning all these other matches for him
just like rhaenyra's father viserys has been
doing for her the other joke you can make about
that too is when viserys was arguing with renera
about her being born female and how the rules
were so much more stricter about her behavior
technically if you were a Highborn person in
a really powerful family like the velaryons or
obviously the targaryens the royal family you
basically had no choice in who you eventually
got married to so most the time marriage amongst
those types of people was more of like a contract
like your business partners rather than lovers
which is why infidelity in those situations
is such a common thing you notice the Wedding
Banquet is taking place in the red keep Iron
Throne Room the Iron Throne is right behind them
the banners behind their houses to symbolize their
match for the most part it seems like all the
most powerful houses in the realm are here at
The Wedding Banquet in the trailer when viserys
is giving his toast he says I hope to Herald into
second age of the dragons and you see the two new
dragons one of them is sea smoke not a new Dragon
because we saw him in episode 3 but the one on
the right is actually meleys princess rhaeny's
Dragon she's another female dragon her nickname
is the Red Queen and before rhaenys claimed meleys
when she was young she was written by viserys'
mother Alyssa Targaryen who they talked about
during episode 4 as well when viserys was joking
in the godswood about how his and Daemon's mother
loved Daemon more because he was such a rogue
kind of like she was in how like Daemon their
mother cared not for ceremony or tradition in fact
there's a funny story about viserys and his mother
after he was born a couple months after he was
born like when he was still like a really tiny
little baby his mother's trapped him in like a
tiny little baby pouch and took him Dragon riding
on melees much to the dismay of all the maesters
even though Dragon bonding when children are born
is a very big thing like they put dragon eggs
in their bassinets usually the maesters would
advise the Targaryen family to wait until children
were like a little bit older before letting them
ride on dragons just because it is actually kind
of dangerous but this is the way to show you how
much of Daemon and viserys's mother was a rogue
and didn't really care about any of that stuff she
like literally took this tiny little baby and took
him Dragon riding for a little while big reminder
too like we make all the twin says jokes all the
sister wiving in the Targaryen family but viserys
and Daemon's mother were brother and sister they
weren't actually twins so you can't technically
call it twin sets but it was a happy marriage
between the two of them so just a way to show
you that like a lot of the targaryens didn't think
that it was weird that they would get it on with
the people that they were closely related to in
the case of their mother and father very closely
related on the flip side of that though on the
negative side you can blame a lot of the declining
Health like the genetic issues that this air seems
like he has on and his parents being so closely
related as people file in The Wedding Banquet you
see the Lannisters walk in Criston Cole meeting
with Alicent Hightower like I said a lot of the
drama of what happened in episode 4 with Criston
Cole and rhaenyra probably winds up coming out
and that's probably why everybody goes crazy
at The Wedding Banquet it'll be interesting to see
who sets the match on this Tinderbox here like who
is the person that leaks the information remember
larys the clubfoot is like the really big gossip
but like there are other people who found out
about what happened or might know what happened
or think that they know and are just telling
rumors at the actual banquet the whole idea
is that even if you aren't as smart as someone
like Tyrion in getting information like even if
you don't know all the secrets in the realm there
are a lot of rumors that get passed around about
characters particularly about rhaenyra so even
if everybody doesn't get all the information
everybody does wind up talking about it eventually
when the actual fighting breaks out in the
wedding scene like I said Criston Cole attacking
Joffrey Lonmouth here remember I explained his
relationship with Laenor Velaryon the person here
this is Harwin Strong punching one of the guards
this is Daemon in the veil with his wife Ria Royce
after being banished there by viserys but you also
notice that he's there at The Wedding Banquet so
they do allow him back for the Wedding Banquet it
looks like viserys's health is getting even worse
but remember not a lot of time has gone by since
the end of last week's episode so he has probably
tripped up on milk of the poppy right now we'll
see how many more digits he winds up losing
by next week's episode I don't know exactly
how many time jumps we're gonna see before they
actually transition to the older versions of the
characters I believe that happens in episode
6. like this might be the last episode with
Millie allacock the younger version of renera the
younger version of alicent as well then you hear
Otto Hightower on his way out of the red keep like
he's been banished so he's obviously leaving the
red key telling alicent that she needs to prepare
aegon II to rule like he's obviously also got this
plan in his head about aegon sitting on the Iron
Throne despite currently rhaenyra being the heir
so just because he's down and out doesn't mean
that he's completely quit the Game of Thrones so
to speak and you see Rhea Royce's wife fall on her
like her horse literally spills over on top of her
so I don't know how she survives this if she does
wind up dying it would be hugely advantageous to
Daemon like he's been asking for that to happen
for the last several episodes I think the bigger
question would be if she does wind up dying in
this accident is it just a coincidence or did
Daemon have something to do with it like did he
orchestrate her death because if you actually look
what's going on in this scene when her horse gets
spooked like he gets spooked by someone wearing a
gray cloak that looks an awful lot like Daemon's
so it looks like Daemon did orchestrate her death
and then even though they don't directly address
it in the trailer there's the whole idea of the
Moon tea did renera take the moon tea is she now
pregnant with Criston Cole's child I talked a
little bit about that during my episode 4 video
because there's a whole rumor in the books that
people call the strong boys her children are
brunettes even though when she's married to
laenor they both have silver hair so you would
expect their children to also have silver hair
but because the time Jump between episode 4 and
episode 5 is so short I don't think that she
would have time to actually be showing unless
they have like a Time jump at the end of the
episode so we might not find out what's going on
with her potential secret children or child with
Criston Cole until episode six but if rhaenyra
really is still pregnant at the end of episode
4 and she didn't take the moon tea the actual
wedding with laenor velaryon like the timing
of it would work out so that her first child
would seem like it's laenor velaryon or they
could say that it's laenor velaryon's the whole
idea as her father explained to her in episode
4 though was that it doesn't really matter what
actually happened it just matters what the realm
perceives to have happened so even if she did
take the moon tea larys clubfoot and the other
gossipers in the realm could be spreading these
rumors about Criston Cole being the baby's father
it was still stick and that would be what people
believe but everyone posts all your theories in
the comments below it is always exciting
when you have a wedding on Game of Thrones
obviously now house the Dragon no different my
full episode 5 video will post next week after
it releases I have a couple bonus videos planned
this week too if you have any questions about what
happened in the episode or any of the characters
just write it below in the comments and I'll try
to add those to my boom videos too there was
a bunch of other announcements too from Marvel
and Star Wars stuff I'll try to do videos for
those as well congratulations Shannon D you're
the giveaway winner from my last big house of
the dragon video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your contact
details everyone click here for my Full House
of the Dragon episode 4 video and click here
for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!